there's a lot of people that we could
always a lot of experts that we could
talk about with and but the Dominion
things specifically that's what we think
would happen there's a lot of experts
that I thought that we could bring that
probably give us some information on
this Dominion thing but there's only one
person that really came to mind for me
let's get the gang back together
I'm loving it
you think Chris you think Chris Cuomo
right now is like you know does it feel
too [__] good does it boys does it
feel too [__] good boys
yeah I don't think Tucker cares as much
as you Chris let's get after it
it's a little [__] bread Tucker's
probably fly fishing right now not
giving a [__] they probably went to
Tucker and they said you are not to ever
talk about Dominion ever again and then
he let out that high-pitched laugh he
always says
okay all right well I'm leaving do you
want to bet you did it you wanna bet oh
[__] but today we are going to start
with this big news and you're going to
get a different take coming out of me
he's a little different almost different
he's a different guy he's he's all mad
at you yeah he's a thing he's his own
free thinking man yeah he's a modern day
philosopher oh he's like a guido Nichi
about the news today Fox News settled
all right
787.5 million dollars and that number is
everywhere and it's the whole story for
everybody and for me it is just the
beginning I think they got off easy
whoa
they got what do you say how did they
get off easy they got charged a billion
dollars by the way you're not gonna hear
you're not gonna hear what everybody
else is saying literally everybody else
on the left is saying what you're saying
Chris you absolute hack but they they
don't they paid almost a billion dollars
for doing what all of you guys do which
was to either lie or get things wrong
they cheat they steal yeah except Eddie
Guerrero was cool but [__] CNN and
MSNBC do the same [__] every day and
nobody gives a [__] about them they mean
they literally pushed poison on you for
profit and nothing
oh
okay for nothing
and then they make people get the poison
to three more times to be able to go to
church
and that's it who lives in a place where
the churches were allowed to open right
there's liquor stores hey flash dancers
hey what's that shout out flash dancers
I got some nice advertising in there and
look who's in front of it the guy who
owns flash dancers
and the guy on the left is the guy that
goes to flash dancers we have everybody
and he's the guy who also owns the
building that they lease that for Flash
dances
see I lease it to myself and it's a tax
write-up
reasons in their suit against Dominion
voting machines and I don't like that
there was a settlement I told you that
last night I'll tell you more about it
yeah guys the totally not evil company
called Dominion voting machines
that was the name of the main bad guys
from Deep Space Nine
seriously it was a 1.6 billion dollar it
was right that's right he's a minion War
was what Dominion was asking for uh Fox
for what their lawyer gal ducat came out
and he see Kardashian
came house and he says we mean you no
harm
the bad guys from Deep Space Nine were
literally shape shifters there were
odo's people they were literally
shape-shifters I'm not saying that as a
joke that's what they were
action lies again and again and again
about dominions voting machines okay
that led to harassment death threats but
destroyed Dorothy in the chat has a good
point is this was Justin being sure and
nobody questions the election ever again
yeah and it's just it was just a now
you'll never question Dominion voting
systems ever again you're not allowed
because they want a lawsuit and anytime
you bring up any kind of election [__]
now they're gonna go hey bro that
lawsuit was already settled pal and then
they go oh Fox you're not allowed to
talk about Dominion ever again but what
if you do something in the future and
get caught they're not allowed to report
on that a little weird this Dominion
thing is ridiculous and realize
something that ever since ever since
notice that Juliana have you seen
Giuliani on Fox News he hasn't been on
anymore now since the Dominion [__]
what's her name [__] Susie Kraken she
hasn't showed up anymore
Susie Kraken her because they're not
going to let them on anymore because
that's it these people they want they
will now use the [__] power of the
and what Fox News did I will agree with
Cuomo except on a different way what
what they did by settling is what Marsha
said you legitimize them now boy We're
not gonna be able to do anything now you
can't do anything now you can't say
anything now every election even if they
cheat right in front of your [__]
eyes you're not allowed to say anything
well they already did cheat right before
our eyes no they didn't it's been
settled by a lawsuit
see how that's going to feel now that's
the first one you got it's gonna happen
all the time now get ready pizza boxes
and about dominions voting machines okay
those were excuse me
those were those were privacy enhancing
Pizza squares that they were putting on
the Windows yes thank you privacy
enhancing Pizza squares yes thank you it
was just Italian window treatments
that's all it was which is it would not
to be confusable with Italian women
treatment with just two black eyes
harassment death threats but destroyed
the Goodwill of the business or not to
be confused with Italian Window Washers
uh who you don't see anymore nowadays
because it's mostly Mexicans yeah I know
it's true and the other thing but it did
a lot to the media also and that has to
be kept in context okay the deal will
provide yes you work at news Nation now
why are you speaking on behalf of the
media but this next party seems this
part's the part that I was that I think
is why Tucker left deal will prevent the
Network's biggest stars uh Carlson
Hannity Bartiromo even Rupert Murdoch
himself from taking the stand and I'm
sure they didn't want that right because
Dominion had the receipts on just one
level of Discovery but they also don't
have to it's gonna wear like a mid 50s
Guy saying things like the receipts on a
News Network you should say the T yeah
sure well no T is what he's on saying
Their audience as a function of this
settlement that's one of the big
problems all right but let's get to the
panel about it let's let's spill the trt
I'm gonna spill some trt right now my
nipples are super sensitive I forgot my
Clomid today [__] me
his nipples are like [__]
Schwarzenegger's and Junior
um let's see whose panel is I'm sure
it's a crack team so it is the biggest
who are these people does anybody know
the one on the the one the one next to
the to the left of him is clearly Benny
the jet Rodriguez what he looks like now
he grew up and he did become a
journalist right right yeah yeah he's
been either reporter Rodriguez and then
the black girl in the middle is just an
average girl the Marshall date and then
the one on the left is is I don't date
ugly black women stop this please the
one on the left is royalty-free uh
royalty free Geraldo Rivera so that's
what you're dealing with here that's
this big his big crew the guy all the
way to the left looks like that guy
that's Typecast as The Honorable
newspaper reporter yes we're really
trying to get to the bottom of the story
in every movie [__] Ned Flanders
looking ass
number we've ever seen attached to
anything like this are you impressed by
the number I am totally impressed by
this is
that what that is no and I predicted
they were going to settle I know you
didn't want them to settle but they had
no choice but they settle because you
can't put this it is I knew it I know
scumbags when I see him work done he
looks weird and different I don't and
he's calmer too that's I think I didn't
recognize him because he's always like
hey oh you got Banning sucking his old
[__] [__] over here and he's much
more subdued no I guess that threw me
because they contradicted themselves on
the air they lied about the election but
the great thing for the 2024
presidential election well they're going
to cheat and then they're going to
[__] Gaslight you into [__] saying
that you're that you're wrong for
questioning it that's the best it really
is like dating a psychopath it's what
this is it's our relationship with the
media is like dating a psychopath it's
like dating a psychopath except I can't
walk away from this relationship I'm
legally not allowed
no
you know what I mean it's like it's like
dating a psychopath woman who also has
happens to have an army
that could come to your house and murder
you mean like black Cleopatra
who's black she was a queen into Warrior
man well she's dead it's gonna be super
tough for Donald Trump to get election
lies and election disinformation into
the marketplace now because I don't
think there's room for it anymore Fox
like they saw this coming with that
comment why Fox doesn't even have to
apologize Lindsay yeah and I think
that's part of the problem why would
they have to apologize did you apologize
for helping your brother yeah I don't
remember you apologizing did you guys
apologize for all the covet stuff did
your brother apologize for the ass
grabbing he did in the [__] over
there did he apologize to that cop that
he sent the [__] Saskatchewan
to be because he was [__] his
daughter yeah did he apologize for not
even being able to eat like sausage
around a woman without turning into some
kind of [__] sexual thing oh yeah
that's a good point at Como did you
apologize for lying about your
quarantine and yelling at a [__] old
elderly man on a bicycle yeah could you
apologize for that do you apologize for
melting down on some guy for calling you
Fredo and then comparing it to the
n-word remember that one Yo God that was
[__] top tier of course I remember
that do you apologize for pretending
doing tricep curls with 150 pound bells
fake ones by the way
huh did you apologize for having a show
on Sirius XM
Jesus everyone should apologize for
having a show on SiriusXM except Ron
Bennington yes no did you apologize for
all the birds you've murdered on your
[__] daily walks you piece of [__]
bird serial killer yeah seriously Chris
because I know I was speaking to friends
earlier and you have no friends
you have white people who are say who
you have white people who are nice to
you there's a difference
was about the idea that everyone who
watches Fox News like white people that
invite you to lunch so they don't look
racist yeah you know who you are the
ones that go I have a black friend
you're the black friend
say the election was stolen from
president trump it was
the election was absolutely stolen I
believe the election was so what my
partner Royce Lopez here is saying and I
just want to tell the fine folks that
Dominion voting machines
that there's nothing creepy or dystopian
or authoritarian in any of your
messaging and I think you guys are doing
great work over there I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry what who's doing great
work who's doing great work uh
Dominion voting machines
these are the good guys Corporation
these are the good guys yeah are they
good like Bane Capital was remember that
one Capital very good company uh goes
and it saves other companies by buying
them and firing everyone that reminds
everybody's sponsor Satanism LLC they're
a great company they they rebuild
orphanages you really should check it
out
oh
but the difference is a journal look
first if you can't trust the good folks
oh
at Dominion voting systems
then who can you trust really if you
can't trust the the the cardassians and
the [__] uh the romulans then what
the [__] who else can you try it's
nobody yeah well we're gonna just be uh
racist to everybody what pointy is oh
[__] man it's not a world I want to live
in Jesus Christ be careful with the
ferangi though they play Both Sides to
see who comes out on top and now [__]
fox has to come up with 800 million
latinum gold pressed yes plenty to get
he makes it all the casino and [__]
deep for whatever reason they don't need
money in the future but he had a casino
what was that about maybe they were
betting the rations oh yeah oh they were
that's a good point yeah that's what
they didn't Voyager when they ran out of
like we have no money so what we need to
plot they're like oh there's replicator
rations now they never was before by the
way but they needed them like yeah
whatever this replicator rations now and
then also why don't you just I don't
know
have Infinity replicator rations for
everybody everyone's yeah why don't you
just make another replica with a
replicator exactly now you have double
the [__] rations what are you doing
now you can crank the replications out
come on Janeway you're my favorite
Captain what are you doing
yes team was my favorite Captain I think
yeah she's better than Picard
barring all the recent Picard [__] which
but like overall as a matter of fact let
me just help you out here at the third
season of Picard is fantastic because
I've heard that you want to know they
got Star Trek next Generation writers to
go in I heard they shut it the [__] down
they got rid of all the shitty people
they brought back the whole OG crew
wrote a [__] really good story and it
was awesome and it's the same tone yeah
it felt like yeah because everything was
in a [__] super fight laser battle
like they were doing in the other ones
Picard actually used I don't know his
brain it was actually pretty good it's
supposed to be some kind of wacky
incident they overcome it somebody at
the end says something funny and you
know and then they fade out it's pretty
simple this year was really like there
was a scene where Warf sees the Riker
and Indiana are married obviously Worf
shows up for the first time in a long
time and the first thing morph does it
starts hitting on the end again like it
has been a million moons that I've since
I have missed you and Riker literally
goes seriously right next it was so
funny it was so well done but anyway uh
what were we talking about oh sorry I
for forgot we were talking about we were
talking about Dominion voting systems
and how they're totally on the level
and that we didn't rig the election we
fortified it remember that they said
that
how a group of Corporations and
billionaires got together
to fortify the election
Dominion voting systems that's no moon
that's a ballot Harvester
oh we're so [__] uh we're kidding
Dominion everything we're saying here is
a giant you guys are cool